(engine revving)
(carnival music)
- The first ride is
the straight-wall ride.
The second act is our go-kart.
So it's four wheels this time.
Third act, it's riding one
of these lovely ladies.
And we do hands-off,
standing up hands-off,
sitting on the side, standing on the side,
a whole array of acts.
It's an experience you can't compare
anything in the world to.
I'm Kerri Cameron and
I'm a Wall of Death rider
and I ride for Luke Fox's
original Wall of Death.
- See the Hell Riders race this afternoon.
We'll take you way back in time.
Back to the late 1920’s ...
- I started riding the Wall
of Death by pure accident.
(somber music)
I used to work with horses ...
And unfortunately, where I was
working the place shut down.
So naturally, we went to the job center
and I just typed in horse
rider into the search engine
and Wall of Death rider came up.
And I went down to the yard
and they had the wall built up.
I knew there and then that was it.
(suspenseful music)
You do get very dizzy when
you first learn to ride
because you've got to
build your stamina up
to the dizziness.
(child screams in delight)
You have to be going at least
30 mile an hour to stay on
otherwise gravity will
just whip you straight off.
It’s a mixture of three things,
so balance, speed and
obviously a bit of stamina.
Just lifting your arm up to wave goodbye
to the audience is quite a feat.
- Ladies and gentlemen ...
Kerri Cameron.
(cheers)
(carnival music)
- It is a good feeling
being a female rider
in this masculine environment.
It gives me a great buzz
because a lot of people,
when they see you walk into the wall,
they just think you're a
bit of flash, you know.
But as soon as they see
you get on the bike,
you can hear like murmurs saying
"Oh, there's a girl on a motorbike."
See all their faces light up.
And then after the show, all
the girls they're all like wow,
you've got bigger balls
than most of the men.
(laughs)
But it's great to know that
they're looking at you thinking
well if you can do it, then so can I.